Shopper recorded shoving crossbow into
his sweatpants at Florida store well
that checks out right already that's why
you wear sweatpants to a store yeah and
I can steal this is this a is that a
crossbow in your pocket are you just
having a seat so that's what they said
stick around
hey guys if you're like me you want the
best for your doggy maybe you feed them
kibble recommended by a vet or a fresh
food diet but did you know that these
are often low in protein high in carbs
and are the leading cause of weight
Mobility dental and skin conditions so
true that's where Maeve comes in maves
raw food diet is formulated to meet your
dog's needs make the switch to Raw today
right now Maeve is offering 40 off your
first order at meatmave.com DPT go to
meetmave.com DBT that's spelled out
m-a-e-v to receive forty dollars off
your first order that's m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v
dot com slash DPT Tony's this show is
sponsored by betterhelp it's so easy to
get caught up in what everyone else
needs from you and never take a moment
to think about what you need from
yourself well therapy can give you the
tools to find more balance in your life
so you can keep supporting others
without leaving yourself behind find
more balance with better help visit
again let me do that find more balance I
got it I got
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com DBT today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
help.com DPT great hey townies welcome
to another episode of dumb people Town
population
how are you good I'm glad I chimed in
with the time
I tried to Zing it over here you all
pointed at me that's why
your gamer you're ready for it you are
so much fun we had you on the show
before we had to have you back on the
show now that we're all part of the all
things comedy family yeah it is a great
podcast you have uh you are a phenomenal
follow on Tick Tock and on Instagram and
we'll tell everyone how to do that we'll
do all that later we got dumb to deal
with stuff stuff happening
you can send them to us just at Daniel
Van Kirk at uh Brothers hashtag young
people town we'll know when who sent it
when and we get it in the order Jane
help breathing Randy you seem like a lot
of practice
took the one breath challenge okay here
we go sent to my Carleen McDermott
wonderful this comes to us a lot from
The Daily Record what was the daily
record I get that every week yeah not
daily weekly once a week I weekly get
the daily record this is just a dumb fun
thing I love it Tesco Shopper gets Club
Card tattooed on arms so he never misses
Supermarket deals so when you go to
Ralph's you go like where's my card to
get the discount he just he just now
like a holocaust Survivor points to his
inner arm and goes so guys there's a
Whole Foods nearby my house not a
bragging but
I was in line and they're like love is
like settled down I know stuff on the
thing they're like if you show your you
can do it where your the palm of your
hand can be your payment
there's like I don't need Whole Foods
knowing like what my palm print is so I
was like I'm in a murderer I'm like what
if I'm walking and on my wallet and I'm
Amy's like can you go pick something I
can just go in there and show my palm
and do it yeah so I did it and then like
the next three days my bank basically
called me because I use my bank card and
I called me and they're like what are
you doing what are you doing I'm like
it's Whole Foods they wouldn't do
anything oh really like they admonished
me like I was a bet like they're my
grandmother what are you doing like
based on what Jay just said yeah went
after me
yeah his Savers card tattooed onto his
arm
a scaffolder
yeah I I can bring you to the point when
you're about to come but then like all
right
he has a podcast called scaff infection
we set up the podcast but then we allow
someone else to come do it yeah yeah he
had his Tesco Club Card permanently
tattooed onto his arm that's how they
work because he kept forgetting to take
it with him when he visited the
supermarket Dean Mayhew said he thought
about this should be Allah in the middle
of them
Dean Mayhew said he thought about the
tattoo for several months before
deciding to go under the needle clearly
told her no one about it yeah it sounds
like a surgically planted in his skin
under the needle he said he doesn't put
it into his dick and like never have to
get erect in order to know the number
but never I told his girl that's up to
the counterfeit yeah I mean there's a
lot of stuff that can get you excited to
Tesco have you been around the melons uh
he said he thought about it for several
months before deciding to go under the
needle he said despite shopping in Tesco
up to three times a day that's all
that's too many times right three times
I mean are you forgetful he regularly
found himself having to pay more because
he forgot his loyalty card so he got the
QR code for his card tattooed onto his
right form and it works perfectly under
the scanner at the till two weeks later
the Tesco closed
Tesco goes out of business
now he gets Club card points and gets
discounts on groceries every time he
shops you mean just like if he had his
car with him yes it just scanned my
forearm and he literally can't forget to
bring it with him I'm gonna I just want
us to start painting the picture of this
guy how old do you think Dean mainly I
want to say I'm going to say like early
40s okay Hot or Not hot oh it's
disgusting scaffolding it's covered
in early 40s gross I'm gonna say 43.
okay I'm gonna say 36 okay I'm gonna say
24. Okay Dean Mayhew
is
30 years old oh my God he looks way
older now he's pretty good looking guy
he told me he was the Prime Minister you
know what I'd [__] him he's actually not
and you know what all right
um he also his shirt
AF scaffolding Limited
wow Dean said uh people just say that
it's typical me sometimes I'm not you
know what that means he's fine sleeping
on a floor yeah yeah he's always I'll
take the floor that is 100 and do a
little improv scene of his two uncles
who haven't seen him for a while okay on
the phone okay okay has Dean ever gotten
over that head injury well no did you
hear what he did last week no what
happened typical Dean he got a tattoo on
his arm oh yeah someone should have had
that head injury looked at her typical
Dean like he had a brain event like that
he fell off some scaffolding well here's
the thing if he has he looks at these
other bad tattoos once you get one bad
tattoo sure which I know about wildly I
have a deer on my foot no reason once
you get one back whole foot is a deer no
reason it's unnecessary no don't show
because then you're gonna end up on Wiki
feet
because it was that bad it went to
it was huge I thought it was going to be
tiny and now it's big and it's huge what
numbers
yeah my foot my one foot got a lot
bigger um this is I think this was
number ten okay number ten okay do you
like the feeling of I am Dean yeah I
like the feeling of getting the tattoo
do you like the pain no you're just this
is something you you put up with you
just like it afterwards yeah okay it's
here for the art oh by the way how in
the world did you walk in shoes post
that tattoo I just I I open toes oh and
like limped everywhere yeah for a while
I bought my eyes off Dean said this is
his full quote people just say it's
typical me sometimes I'm not the
cleverest of guys but they've said that
for me it's pretty genius what okay
translation brain injury
falling on his head I haven't even
gotten to the crazy this is all one
quote oh he's still going
to talk
the show's gonna come to a stop people
just say it's typical me sometimes I'm
not the cleverest of guys but they said
that for me it's pretty genius I've got
seven kids what no I've got seven kids
and I'm in there all the time probably
three times a day I'd say what this time
30 years old when he says in there all
the time he's talking about his wife
how do you get seven kids you're in
there all the time oh my God in and out
of seven kids seven kids seven kids at
30. this guy's he's never pulled out of
anything in his life okay especially his
card that's why yeah that's the one
thing he never pulled out
quote I've been thinking of getting the
tattoo for the last three to four months
every time I go in there they ask if I
got my club card but it's always at home
about getting a tattoo for three to four
months doesn't seem long enough for you
to be it's not gonna get tattooed a year
is what they say a year I've been
thinking about this one for a year every
time I go in there they ask I got my
club card it's I say it's always at home
or I've lost it no [__] you have seven
kids the fact that you know where your
keys are but what about your phone
number we use phone numbers here if we
forget our cards yeah you can still use
the phone I forgot that so maybe this is
a fault of the system yeah
this could have all been taken care of
if Tesco would have done a better job of
like understanding that people are going
to forget their cards yeah a horse from
Sussex from Horsham Sussex that spent
half an hour getting the tattoo earlier
this month he and his tattoo artist Dan
rossetter so he's got a tattoo artist
yeah he's 39 uh has 14. and he
introduces
oh my God I don't know I'm just grading
scale this is my tattoo artist right
uh then visited the local Tesco Express
to find out how it worked I tried the
self-checkout but it was quite awkward
to use because it wasn't doing it uh so
that I had to go to the guy on the till
I went up there and it worked so now
that means also he can no longer
self-check out right so he's like I went
to self-checkout right and you know he
was like okay he told everyone around
watch this watch me so here's him
getting scanned so he now can no longer
do self-checkout if he wants to who's
taking that picture probably
someone else is that two artists
he couldn't believe it every time I go
in there they're shocked and it's good
to see people's faces that you could put
that into any story yeah it has nothing
to do with it it's good that might have
just gotten in from a different story
it's good to see people's faces I could
use the one on my phone okay all right
no no no no no no no so he's had one on
his phone the whole time
that ran from 1991 to 1991. I bet you
Dean and I swear to God couldn't tell
you the chronological ages of his kids
no like I bet there's no way he could be
like this is this one and this you got
it tattooed no there's no way
I couldn't believe it every time I go in
they're shocked it's good to see
people's faces I could use the one on my
phone but I want to use the one on my
arm as it's funny anything you can do
with a normal Club card I can do with my
arm okay um except put it in your wallet
yeah right or uh put it away ever it's
constantly or impress an older person or
land a job in short sleeves it's even
dumber the tattoo is still in the
healing process and at the moment it's
still scabby I don't know if it will
still work when it it's healed but I
don't see why it wouldn't oh my God
he's on a maybe this will work basis
because those are thin lines too unless
you got a big what's the sizing
uh it's I'll show you another pick of it
he goes I gotta read this other quote
damn I don't regret stuff I'm not one of
those people
no [__] clearly you've got seven kids I
don't think it looks bad I think it
looks pretty cool looked it's still
there it's like don't talk about it in
the past then and then pretty cool is
not selling me that's not hard enough I
don't think it looks bad I think it
looks James yeah it's like Jay went to
Machu Picchu I went to Machu Picchu and
my gag was to be like a southern
American who's kind of impressed by this
thing but not but loudly over other
people's videos
I mean it's pretty good I don't know it
ain't straight it's pretty it's pretty
good what do you think I think tattoo
Dean it's pretty cool literally ruining
every other person's pristine how do you
think it's pretty good it's pretty good
I like it I'm not saying I don't like it
I just think it's pretty good yeah two
artists Dan who I don't know why they're
still in this story oh no Dennis said
I've been tattooing for 12 years so I've
seen a lot but I've never seen a Tesco
Club card as an idea before this is not
that original people do barcodes yeah
sure that's not an idea at first like
the Tesco card isn't an idea it's not
like he came up with a creative he
didn't have a creative inspiration I'm
like Tesco didn't have cards and he's
like I'm gonna give you the idea for a
card to swipe if Tesco said hey if you
get a Tesco tattoo you get a free loaf
of bread every week for the rest of your
life
yeah like remember UCB used to have the
UCB tattoo if you had a UCB tattoo the
logo with the eyes and stuff you got
into every show but it had to be across
your forehead I had to also be in front
of a swastika yes
but it covered this one it did cover it
right
tips of all the swastika arms
could have been a wheel uh he said I'm
doing 12 years never seen this idea
before at first I said are you sure you
want to do this but I saw the fun within
it and thought let's do it okay Dan I
was anxious about it hands kind of
claiming like he could have stopped it
at something yeah yeah yeah I was
anxious about how well it was likely to
work as it's an inch intricate barcode
but Dean was quite relaxed about it and
was going for the fun aspect he said if
it didn't work it wasn't the end of the
world yeah Dean go watch your kids and
go remember where you're throw your card
in the car yeah they don't have the
thing like Ralph says the keychain thing
too yes
it's on his phone I did the tattoo and
we decided to pop into the Tesco down
the road we went to the self-service
checkup but because we already know this
story we literally already covered this
once Dan's telling us again because the
way the scanner is situated he couldn't
get his arm flat enough and we thought
it didn't work and then we went to we
went to the till and a person with a
scanner tried to listen and make it
first that this is weird and go it
worked whatever Dean's face lit up and I
realized he was drunk I'm joking
but I realized it did work so here
they're just going around Tesco was like
sir I need to get back to work Jessica
doesn't care that that guy is so
unimpressed with him has no interest
welcome to the club stamp that guy just
had his hair relaxed
look at Dean's left arm he's just trying
to flex so hard oh of course
they're just the flex just come on Dean
uh we're back to Dean talking again I
think this is almost like an oral
history
how many times do you want to just be
like we're almost done dead there were
less words written about like the war in
Ukraine yeah
whatever this comes out uh quote I think
I'm always quite quite a fun outgoing
type of guy no one said you weren't so
no one said no one and this doesn't make
you more yeah this doesn't prove that no
so it was a so it was a bit of banter
and there is this element of it being a
genius idea it's not a genius idea you
don't get to call it genius it's not
something I would have come up with I
said it's horrendous yes it's it's like
he LOL his own joke he's a loser you
can't laugh out loud at your own joke
you someone else can LOL
he didn't say it was genius it's not
something I would have come up with off
the top of my head to be honest I
thought it was quite cool Dean also
admitted that he has considered getting
a nectar card from when he stops stops
at stains or Sainsbury's I don't know
what that is because he often forgets
that too right I did think about getting
another one but that's a whole other
thing it's another tattoo Dean why is it
a whole other yeah yeah at this point
put it right next to that one yeah this
is when the reporter lets Dean talk too
much okay I quite often go between
Sainsbury's and Tesco's who cares can I
forget that card too I'd get a nectar
card tattooed on me I'd probably get it
on the same arm just above the Tesco one
really I've already got one so why not
the year there's a girl who's seven and
she smokes yeah and a bird had wings but
the bird couldn't fly
the Scaffolding in the back of his head
large that no one's taken there's no way
so now are you convinced that he's had a
brain incident yes he's talking I've had
a few people suggest the sainsbury one
when I posted it on Facebook no [__]
I would be doing that I would be doing
next or next and I thought that was a
good idea I disguise I'm I'm reading
someone's what I did over summer
and here's what each of them said about
it and then my dad left for a while and
he told me the turtle thing was not the
reason he was leaving all right
he still loves me even though he's not
going to see me for a long time I did
try and have a look on the internet and
I reckon I'm the only person well sounds
like you covered it yep we'll get out of
here I tried to find someone else with
them and no one else has got them I'd be
the only person with both great no the
only person with seven kids yeah either
you're unique you're the only person
I've ever known who's called himself a
scaffolder he's also still talking to
reporter and he's not there no yeah
he's still doing left a recorder and
that was it wrong there you go store
number one down the book story number
one when we come back we'll let you know
how you can see steps you can see her
follow her and all of that great stuff
and uh stuff we have going on it's dumb
people down don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get into Story number two and before
we tell you how you can follow Steph to
love we're going to give you a little
information on us uh we are going to
continue to mention this until it
happens we are going to be in Phoenix at
stand up live it is an enormous Club it
is wonderful it's the last weekend of
March into April 1st April Fool's Day
will be there live Jeffrey baldinger uh
will be featuring for us it's uh March
30th 31st and April 1st I love that club
I love Phoenix we always have great
audiences let's sell these but let's
fill it out with dumb people Town fill
it out with DPT fans we'd love it come
see us there we'll be in Austin at moon
tower Comedy Festival
but we'll be at moon tower and then in
May we'll be the third week in May we'll
be in uh Minneapolis at the Acme Comics
it's been a while and then in the fall
we have a couple dates we'll be in Ann
Arbor Springfield Missouri and then
we're kind of building up the rest of
those dates we'll let you know uh when
all that stuff's happening if we're
doing another season of the nosebleeds
all that stuff just keep tuning into
this also join our patreons we have one
for dumb people town and one for scholar
Brothers where we do um that's a great
way to support exactly Daniel what do
you have going on I have uh I'll be
Mentor with you guys obviously we're
doing double time but then I'm doing a
whole bunch of stand-up shows and living
wake uh the week before that I'll be in
Houston for would you rather comedy show
people come on to that show it's really
great you're just gonna stay in Texas
and then I don't know man you might yeah
and then uh
what uh other weekend after the uh the
last weekend in April I'll be headlining
in Denver uh with the grolics boys
everything is a Daniel van kirk.com all
right Steph tolev a phenomenal follow-on
Tick Tock I'm going to say it right now
your thing about per what was it like
the Vancouver person who's like look at
the mouse it's so accurate look at those
the amount of people that actually like
talk about the cab that day and he's
like the mountains are great today I was
like I'm not you camera like stop
telling me that so I laugh at everything
you post on there and so everyone just
do a quick immediate follow-up great
stand up on there great characters and
stuff you've really you've really in my
opinion I feel like you and Adam Ray
have both like figured it out how to do
great content put lots of different
things up there on the reg I love it so
it's just a nightmare but thank you
anyway
what does this come out yeah probably
middle of March yeah okay
um yeah I'll be South White is otherwise
March 10th 12th then I'll be in uh
Birmingham Alabama March 17th 18th then
I will be in Kansas City the weekend
after that whatever those dates are yeah
um yeah and then I'm in Houston at the
Riot Fest somewhere in there as well I'm
on the road every weekend in March so if
you like me then you can find me uh you
can find her find her stephtolov.com
let's just go to my my Instagram
I love it all right well please go see
her live she's so much fun dirty AF oh
yeah I hate clean it ain't clean don't
bring Nana and people no no no no don't
bring me Mom and people out of this one
because you want to see
about that later they're swingers man if
they're down for it then bring them yes
Jay you got a story I do this is sent in
by uh Tim kleinsmith uh at attacking
windmills okay uh taking will Mills I
think either way attack
um all right here we go police robot
told woman to go away after she tried to
report a crime then sang a song
so the robot sang a song okay I don't
think the woman tried to report a crime
then get the [__] away from me get the
[__] away from me get the [__] away from
me you crazy [__] not a bad song you
guys knew that already
that's what's crazy to me is that so the
the robot we're all worried about AI I
do actually think about it I do there
are moments around my wife is nice to
Alexa because she's like when the robots
come you better be nice to Alexa thank
you so much Alexa set a timer for five
minutes thank you so much and I hope
you're having a good day today I'm like
you don't need to ask that's crazy
that's too much honey you're adding that
to it you don't need to add that uh it
doesn't know what's going on with you
stop saying what's going on with you
Alexa
Coco guebara sounds like a wrestler who
had like two parrots on his shoulder
came into the ring with Coco Guevara
would break both their necks
MMA fighter golfer from the late 80s
maybe like started the revolution in
Cuba maybe or is a koala bear yes it's
just a full name
did you hear that at the San Diego zoo
keepers syphilis I can't believe that
you don't touch it and that's so weird
don't judge because they carry chlamydia
not syphilis it's the one Coco bear
groundbreaking with groundbreaking it
could be siblings
so Coco gobert rushed over to the
motorized police officer and pushed its
emergency alert button on seeing the
brawl breakout in Salt Lake Park Los
Angeles last month so by the way let's
see where the story starts so let's just
see what who who Salt Lake Park Los
Angeles that's not real I can't figure
we all live here also good on her for
like trying to stop something and going
to an authority would you even know what
that thing was to go push a button and
say something no I'm picturing the robot
from
um robocup no no yes Johnny number five
no what's the one what's the cartoon oh
wait oh oh Wally no my God not it's a
it's like a Hannibal bear cartoon sounds
like uh it's a it's a woman cartoon oh
from The Jetsons yes that's what I'm
picturing the Jason's robot is it going
around the park Iona yeah
yeah
upside down yes that's what I'm
picturing wait but so normally wait
Aaron what was it
but instead of offering assistance the
egg-shaped robot is that derogator do we
need to no it's true so they have these
at uh Kaiser yeah yeah they like go
around and how big is it they're pretty
tall really I'd say about five and a
half feet tall
shaped robots in your life hey no so do
you know that my 14 year old son what he
likes to do with his skateboarding
friends is get in front of those robot
food deliveries
yes and try to knock them off track oh
don't do that
those are put out there for 14 year old
boys
like they're asking to be pushed over
yeah
um whose official name is HP RoboCop
if I only had my card if I only had my
tattoo my Holocaust Tesco card my phone
uh barked at guebera to quote step out
of the way oh okay what the egg bark I
would pay to watch an egg bark to add
insult to injury the high-tech device
then rolled away while humming and enter
while humming an Intergalactic tune
pausing periodically to say please keep
the park clean wow
like a fight's going down right yeah
so basically the egg-shaped top is at
times acting like regular cups so this
is have you guys ever had to hit one of
those like uh like safety boxes or like
yeah a man punched a woman in the face
oh my God homeless and I went over and I
was like oh my God oh my God oh my God
she's bleeding the guy ran off and I was
like like slamming the thing there's two
cops to come down and then the woman uh
started saying horrendous things to the
cops and they didn't want to help her
and I was like well stop yelling that
word yeah stop your yelling it's a bad
word stop with those with those yeah
right but you got to stop with that I'm
trying to help you here we're all
helping and you were still trying
to help me the N word I was like well
was there a party it's like I wonder if
she called him yeah yeah and then he was
like yeah you earned it like I didn't
see the beginning of that yeah whatever
nobody should hit anybody
this person yelling help yeah this goes
over to the egg so it's like let's go
listen this is her quote it just kept
ringing and ringing and I kept pushing
and pushing sounds like this is like
when you lose yourself
that's all Dean does
wake up
pushing in the 9 months later another
kid comes out all right the concern
bystander thought the I told you how
tall it was didn't I no I guessed around
like six feet uh do you want to guess uh
I'll say four good yeah let's say three
feet four and a half feet
get your answers in shout it at your ham
radios these robots these egg-shaped
robots RoboCop uh is five feet tall
that's right my foot tall robot might
have needed to see her face before it
began to work oh so now we're gonna make
excuses for the robot oh it didn't see
her face so I can't sorry New Egg who
this you can't start doing my egg my egg
got my officer egg got hacked so she
crouched down in front of its camera but
the egg-shaped device still didn't work
forcing guebera to call 9-1-1 on her
phone instead she could have called that
forcing could have called the whole time
she could have been on hold with 9-1-1
while punching this second story where
the answer to the problem is right on
your phone on your phone that's it this
is the whole theme of the show officers
from the Huntington Park Police
Department cops finally arrived how many
minutes later how long did it take for
the cops to come
after of course the fight had ended an
hour I would say 60 minutes I'm gonna go
10 10 minutes yeah 18 minutes get your
answers in you say an hour
15 minutes later all right 15 minutes
later the cop showed up uh it left one
woman uh with a bad head wound she was
in the fight which saw her stretches
full-on brawl local police chief cosme
Lozano
Lozano if you told me that is your
favorite dish at like
or it's the name of your character on
the Mandalorian that's right have you
tried the cosmetology his nose is an
oboe you can get a vegetarian cosme
Lozano too yeah it takes longer takes
longer and they do with the impossible
no it's not impossible it's they make
their own
uh says that the robots which cost
between what and what a year to lease
you don't even own them the cops don't
even own these things
let's put the difference okay so if it's
three thousand five thousand the answer
would be four thousand so it's smack dab
in the middle how much does it cost to
lease these a year this is what
where our police dollars are going
towards robots that don't work where
robots that don't pay attention or that
ignore you and then mocking between 10
and 15 000 a year I'm gonna go 12 and a
half thousand dollars what do you think
I'll do other twenty thousand twenty
thousand thirty five thousand a year get
your answers in and shot it loud because
the answer is 65 000. oh my God between
60 and 70. cannot care
oh I'll do that perhaps
more yeah you have to open my comments
into the already living in Parks just
let them okay let them give them a free
banana thank you it's like when you hear
stories like I was listening to the guys
we [__] podcasts and there was like
someone on the podcast who like made
tons of money just guys would call her
up and she would ignore them
leave the phone on yeah just put it down
and then go do housework or just
whatever hang out and do our own stuff
and then you guys like talk to me answer
me and you can just kind of hear it in
the background she's just doing her life
and they're like yeah
that was jerking off I know but I'm
almost
the best way ever to cash in money I
mean like I gotta do this yeah
sixty thousand dollars to ignore people
free use is a whole new type of oh
there's a whole new thing too where guys
apparently send in their dicks and they
want women to rate them like very
meaning mainly yeah
what am I roasting your uh I'm roasting
known on the front Rocky roasting your
[__] are you kidding me
I think these robots were designed to
ignore like important people and so like
they're like no we switched to aggro we
gave the wrong this was a sex robot for
guys who wanted to be ignored in the DJ
robot your [__] looks like Ned Beatty on
Jerry Lewis's prednisone what yeah no
one gets it they're like actually
this guy said
uh let's get a whole cottage industry
going uh it's still in a trial phase
obviously yeah and that their alert
buttons have not yet been activated he
said that law enforcement have not yet
started advertising robots crime
fighting activities I wouldn't until you
get it right wait crime fighting
activities it's not gonna go they're not
fighting crime no they're just do they
have arms or just egg no more eggs but
if it at least go if it had gone to the
problem with your camera on that would
if you can release tear gas from there
then
on that road I mean I don't know why we
just had a robot this past summer who
broke a kid's finger playing chess
against the kid really yeah because the
kid it looked like he let go of his
piece but he was still on it so then the
robot went to like move the piece and
like broke his fingers
so yeah if it's slowly broke it that's
any help requests are currently sent to
a company called night scope
a-n-i-g-h-t scope which creates at least
is the robot come on it's people dressed
as eggs just in a basement just watching
them and then the Commodores are doing
something gonna be some sweet sounds
gonna be dope
wait that was worth it night school
night scope is such a badass it's the
villain from every Beverly Hills Cop
movie what's your company Raytheon
Industries or night Scopes night scope
Incorporated scoping
I found a receipt for night scope Inc I
can't believe anyway they're a direct to
VHS production company
everything let's go yeah let's go who's
paying for the war in Iraq nice scope
does night school have jurisdiction yeah
they're in there no they have Rangers
Jason Bourne took down night skills oh
my God that's Lozano added that once the
robot completes its trial calls made
using its alert button will be sent
straight to dispatch great good
[Laughter]
other versions of the same model have
previously hit the headlines after one
fell into a fountain in Washington DC
yeah well there you go that's what we're
talking about a good day for nice guys
like no no you gotta make them all right
a third HP RoboCop struck a child while
patrolling in a mall in a California
might have been being a brat nope I'm
gonna hand this to you Randy I'm telling
you right now these are this is a
mistake we can cut our losses right now
we don't need to feed the night scope
Beast anymore okay we don't need to feed
the knightscope
had their chance they had their day in
the 80s back to building carnival rides
uh I'm not even gonna tease this next
one we're gonna have a great story on
the outside the break Steph tools is
with us and uh we'll be right back on
dumb people town
[Music]
hey guys I want to talk about uh feeding
your doggy I have little you know this
very well I know I have little Ponyo and
she's great but I worry about her weight
100 sorry about her eating the right
foods that are healthy for her and good
for her and so what I realize don't
worry anymore I don't have to worry
anymore because I've got Maeve I love
Maeve so much it's raw food it comes in
little cubes and I put it in her food in
in her dish and she loves it so much
they're crunchy so it's good for her
teeth good for her weight I know she's
getting like really really good food so
it has been wonderful and the transition
of her on to the mave was fantastic and
easy and I'm telling you it's the best
thing I've ever got her yeah dogs need
unprocessed high protein low carb diets
that kibble and Fresh Foods they just
don't deliver Plus what's great about
myth is there's no mess no prep no
thawing I've seen it I've been over your
house I'm like that's it yep that's like
a stew let's make some of that for
herself all you have to do is just open
pour and serve it's that easy people
love Maeve they have over 1 000
five-star reviews so do their dogs they
love it too especially those notorious
picky eaters tell them what they need to
do Jay okay make the switch to Raw today
right now Maeve is offering 40 off your
first order at meatmave.com DPT go to
meet maeve.com TBT that's spelled
m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v to receive forty dollars
off your first order that's
m-e-e-t-m-a-e-v.com slash d p t best
food I've ever served my dog
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
guys it's easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you and never
take a moment to think about what you
need for yourself yes I am this way with
my daughters with my wife there's a lot
of times where I'm like wait a minute am
I taking care of myself right here and
if you don't take care of yourself what
do they say secure your own mask before
you secure the masculine take care of
yourself before you take care and
therapy is a huge part of that talk
therapy and the way you connect with
someone and the way you're able to
unfold your life to a therapist my wife
is a therapist I understand I've been in
my own balance in your life it does give
you balance and it's a way to take care
of yourself there's a moment in our
world and our time where self-care is
super important for our own Survival
that's right how we navigate the world
how we feel about ourselves how we
navigate difficult times our lives are
filled with tough moments and better
help makes it so easy for you guys if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
is designed to be convenient flexible
suited to your schedule all you do is
fill out a little questionnaire and you
get matched with a therapist which
what's cool too is sometimes if you've
never done therapy uh a person can be a
great doctor you can be a willing
participant in those sessions and it not
be a good Max you can switch up your
therapist so easily with better help
it's awesome you can find more balance
with betterhelp visit betterhelp.com DPT
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash d p t do it for
yourself
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show
welcome back uh I will take us home you
guys ready for this all right this one
is sent in by overdue for extinction at
04 e pod well that's a new one a new one
I actually love a new people we
appreciate the the regulars but we like
the new folks thank you for doing that
are you guys ready for this all right
here's the headline Shopper recorded
shoving crossbow into his sweatpants at
Florida store well that checks out right
already that's why you wear sweatpants
to a store yeah and I can steal this is
this is that a crossbow in your pocket
or you just have it a scene so that's
what they said actually it is one of the
world's dumbest criminals was recorded
shoving a crossbonded sweatpants at a
hardware store I mean sweatpants gives
you the confidence that you can stuff
anything down right especially if
they're like dark and thick dark gray
does it say the kind of sweatpants so of
course there is
dark and thick dark and thick
so in a sweatpants at a hardware store
What hardware stores are selling
crossbows all of them in Northern
Illinois
according to the Breville where's the
crossbow in the hardware store it's by
the batteries and the Hemorrhoid pillows
all right so by the Brevard County
Sheriff I love that there's Broward
County there's Brevard County bremered
County anyway it happened on February
6th at a True Value Home Improvement
store in Mims and the man stood in front
of the surveillance camera I mean you
know we had to see that there was a
camera there yeah he pulled open his
sweatpants to hide the Weapon quote just
when you think you've seen it all like
really I love how shocked these people
yeah this isn't that outrageous
people stole something from the sheriff
and you'll tell me I want you each of
you to tell me what profession if he
wasn't a sheriff he'd be doing okay
Brevard County Sheriff Wayne Ivey wrote
on Facebook Wayne Ivey Wayne Ivey what
does Wayne Ivey do if he's not a sheriff
at Brevard County oh I feel like he's a
dean of a [__] Ivy League school
pretty good too I'd be in an Ivy League
school
he's uh he's lead umpire for a little
league uh oh I was gonna say junior
varsity girls high school basketball
coach
semi semi-professional poker player
quote this guy takes carrying a
concealed weapon to a whole new level as
he proves to all of us you can actually
stuff a crossbow down the front of your
pants yeah you can this is yeah these
people are Imagine these people
like now I think the chief is dumber
than all right the man successfully made
it out of the store despite a
conspicuous bulge so so I think people
and a handle's sticking out of his pants
he had a handle sticking out so he
didn't hide the whole thing this tells
you how how little attention people are
paying people either don't care their
jobs or they see it they're like oh no
he's gonna take the crossbow out and
kill everyone in this story
so this is when they figured it out or
if we catch him he's going to come back
to the store with a gun so now we just
can't call anyone on their [__] no you
can't break up with anyone anymore you
can't fire anyone anymore
store staff later discovered true CR two
crossbows were missing I guess when you
do the crossbow have you done your
crossbow count hey someone get over
there do they do the no we're at 78.
well we've only sold 20 today I'm like
we should be at 80. how could they be
that on them how could they just be that
out wouldn't they be behind even a
little while I have to [__] get a guy
to give me razor blades at the at Rite
Aid and Advil you're getting a [__]
Target Advil right the full thing of
Advil said but the crossbows are just
hanging around next to the like
loungewear so they began scrubbing
through surveillance video for
suspicious activity that's when they saw
footage of a customer using a uh using a
stolen cutting tool to remove a raven
r10 crossbow from its packaging hide it
in his pants the hunting bows are how
many inches long
I'm Canadian so I'd say 20 centimeters
how many inches is 20. I don't know I
don't even know if this is afterwards
three centimeters yeah two feet two
thirty Thirty thirty six you say 24. so
I'm gonna say 39 inches okay good
transfers in town he's because this
crossbow is 33 inches long and it weighs
close to how many pounds
eight
seven seven pounds
and retails for how much this is
interesting well that really depends I
actually know this take a guess what do
you think I don't I'd say 200 I've made
250 I don't know 250 what do you think
if it's a decent
obviously 350 bucks what do you think
500 bucks
get your answers in
I mean that's why he needed some sort of
device to cut out of his packaging which
also could have meant that it was
sometimes they have locks on like you
can pick it up but it's Tethered to the
yeah yeah right so he's using a high
power knife to cut through the plastic
that's got that line I mean that's an
expensive crossbow that's a really nice
cross that should not be out on the
store
you got to go talk to Steve he'll go
into a back room
so that's how much they retail for at a
Bass Pro Shop maybe bass is like you
know doing that stuff I said all right
investigators say this is my favorite
line in the whole story so you got away
with it you left I mean yes they can see
you and they can probably track you down
and find you you best not go by there
anymore right
investigator said investigators say the
man resurfaced a few days later and was
captured after a brief Chase across a
Walgreens parking lot yeah you're not
we're not running too fast with that
with
look you can't run with 8 000 greeting
cards in your pants also Walgreens is
like we just let people take it we're
here right stopping anybody whatever you
like whatever you want but like after a
brief like to me how funny Would it be
just it doesn't have the crossbow still
in his I know but I'm just saying
whatever else but he once he got away
with it he's he's sweatpantsed
emboldened like if you this would be
like if you wore sweatpants out and you
got a date while in sweatpants you'd be
like oh I can I can do anything else
it's like your holiday staying at a
Holiday Inn Express people like can you
believe he he stole a crossbow and
sweatpants yeah yeah tell me about a guy
in Caprice
short shorts yeah stealing like a boat
or I'm like holy [__] yeah a lot of
denims how's this guy stealing anything
he's not gonna steal a Bowie it's
amazing if you do that in cut off death
yes if you pick up someone like or hook
up with someone if you haven't taken a
shower like there's someone who's like
am I giving off pheromone I think
like you suddenly feel like that you can
do that that's why that's why he came
back he resurfaced a couple days later
in a Walgreens parking lot thinking I
can do anything and now he's being
chased around yeah yeah yeah the
crossbow confidence there you go
crossbows sweatpants sweatpants
confidences what this guy has
um but if he was smart and he went in
with big sweatpants and a big oversized
shirt with already a limp go away
we just got Kevin Spacey by the way when
you think about Kevin Spacey's career
like the whole of his career like we he
kind of showed himself to me one thing
and then he'd like at the end you start
to figure out like oh my God he laid on
Anthony rapper he's a piece of [__] and
there you go and that's it all right you
guys that is a show that's how we do it
it's dumb people dumb the great stuff to
live follow her on Instagram follow her
name your podcast it's uh Steph
infection staph infection also here
Evans comedy you guys will do it you
gotta do it everyone do it it's about
body image am I right weird body stuff
weird body stuff oh I love it and
everyone has something that's something
gross not gross yeah I love that
everybody does have something and in
some sweet way it makes everybody more
connected because we all have that's
cool infection check that out it's an
all things comedy thing and oh [__] we
gotta get back to work
town
[Music]